for more than two decades the russian
president has been cultivating a strong
man image
he's a judo master who rides horses
swims in a siberian river and scores
goals in hockey against world champions
but in the past few months that image
has been challenged
recent footage of the 69 year old leader
showed him coughing puffy faced or
walking with a stiff right arm feeling
speculation and questions from the media
about his health after two years of
pandemic isolation
in late july intelligence officers
shared their assessments there are lots
of rumors and as far as we can tell he's
entirely too healthy and the kremlin has
repeatedly said he's doing well
so amid the war in ukraine here's why
putin's every public appearance is being
so closely scrutinized
first consider that we're getting very
little information from russia on the
president's well-being good afternoon
everybody unlike the white house that
shares regular health updates for u.s
leaders president biden is currently
experiencing mild symptoms the kremlin
is very tight-lipped on the matter
so videos of a seemingly tired putin
sitting at the victory day parade or
holding the table with both hands during
this televised update about the war in
ukraine
prompted comments by officials and news
outlets around the world about his
fitness
a top ukrainian official told a tv
channel that the russian leader was sick
a newsweek report claiming that american
spies believed putin had been treated
for cancer was widely covered
so journalists have been asking russian
officials about it
yesterday
the wall street journal couldn't
independently confirm those reports and
the leader of a european country told us
he believed putin was healthy still
observers noticed that when putin landed
in tehran he seemed to walk stiffly with
his right arm hanging unnaturally
he also repeatedly coughed and cleared
his throat during and after this trip so
much so that he spoke about it himself
it's obviously hard to draw any
conclusion from this type of footage but
it puts putin's health in the spotlight
even making it a talking point at a
major security forum and prompting
western intelligence chiefs to weigh in
there's no evidence that uh putin is uh
is suffering from serious ill health
what footage from the past couple of
years does show clearly is that the
russian leader appears to take his
physical well-being seriously that's
what these extremely long meeting tables
suggest
in the early days of the pandemic putin
went into isolation in his residence
outside moscow
during two years he mostly communicated
with the outside world via video calls
like most leaders around the world
but even after he started attending more
in-person events during russia's war
with ukraine most of the time the public
has been kept at a distance
the same goes for officials and world
leaders who've often been seated far
away from him
this 16 feet long table was seen several
times during putin's meeting with
france's emanuel macron and germany's
olaf schultz among others the kremlin
said it was keeping in place all the
safety measures to protect the president
from the coronavirus
the health of world leaders is always a
matter of public concern false reports
recently claimed that the ukrainian
president was in intensive care for
example
[Applause]
but for russia heightened scrutiny of
putin's health also brings questions
about how the country would be governed
without its authoritative leader at a
time when he's at the center of global
politics over the invasion of ukraine
for decades moscow has worked hard to
create an aura around one man as the
country's main decision maker who's
believed to directly approve almost all
executive government decisions
the kremlin said that putin's
decision-making powers are limited by
the russian constitution and the
president's spokesman has previously
said moscow isn't looking for a
successor and that means any contingency
plan will likely remain a closely held
secret